cinco años después de anunciar su
erradicación guinea declaró este domingo
una nueva epidemia de ébola es el primer
resurgimiento de la enfermedad desde el
mortífero brote que afectó a varios
países africanos entre 2013 y 2016 los
nuevos casos se detectaron en la región
de nuestro alcohol en el sur este mismo
lugar donde se desató la última epidemia
esta mañana muy temprano el laboratorio
de ser chip conakry ha confirmado la
presencia del virus del ébola lo que
pone a quienes en una situación de
epidemia
los pacientes enfermos con diarrea
vómitos y hemorragias habrían acudido al
funeral de una enfermera a principios de
mes quién sería el paciente cero del
nuevo brote con escasos recursos en uno
de los países más pobres del mundo el
resurgimiento del ébola supone un
esfuerzo sanitario añadido requerido por
la pandemia de kobe 19 y otras
enfermedades virales como el sarampión o
la fiebre amarilla las autoridades
guineanas han solicitado a la
organización mundial de la salud dosis
de las vacunas experimentales contra el
ébola el personal ya está en el terreno
apoyando la vigilancia la prevención y
el control de infecciones y la
participación de la comunidad lado ms
también está apoyando a guinea para
conseguir la vacuna del ébola que ha
demostrado ser fundamental para
controlar los brotes en la república
democrática del congo los países
fronterizos como liberia y sierra leona
han activado sus alertas para evitar la
propagación del virus el de vine a no es
el único rebrote que preocupa al
continente en los últimos días se han
reportado otros casos de ébola en la
república democrática del congo